starting today millions of parents could
see extra money in their bank accounts
thanks to a new expanded child tax
credit eligible families could get up to
300 dollars per month per
child through the end of the year as
part of president biden's american
rescue plan
now some democrats want to make the
payments permanent ed o'keefe reports
from the white house
it's pretty much paycheck to paycheck
since this pandemic started julie page
and her husband lost their jobs during
the pandemic
he found another one but when schools
closed she needed to be at home watching
their five kids
she says the new child tax credit can't
come soon enough
back to school is coming up so all the
kids are gonna need you know clothes and
shoes and things like that
julie says the money will help pay off
bills that piled up during the pandemic
and it allows for a bit of normalcy
after struggling
all year we have a birthday on friday so
we're hoping to be able to do something
fun for her birthday that we otherwise
probably wouldn't do
starting today families making less than
170 thousand dollars per year or
single parents making less than ninety
five thousand dollars begin receiving
monthly payments
that's as much as thirty six hundred
dollars a year for each child under six
three thousand for each child between
six and seventeen
some of the money will come by december
the rest when parents file their 2021
taxes
for now it's just a year-long benefit
but some democrats want to make the
payments permanent
as vermont's bernie sanders told cbs's
chris van cleed
it's enormously significant because
among working families in this country
there is a feeling that the government
has forgotten about
their needs president biden met with
fellow democrats wednesday on capitol
hill to shore up support for a new
3.5 trillion dollar budget plan we're
going to get this done we are
getting this done thank you details are
still being finalized but in addition to
expanding the child tax credits
it could also include expanded medicare
coverage money to fight climate change
and a pathway to citizenship
for certain immigrants republicans won't
back the plan
they say it's too costly so every senate
democrat needs to be on board in order
for the plan to pass
and some moderates aren't there yet i
want to make sure that
the priorities that we have is what we
need in our country and i
get a chance to look at that in detail
lawmakers still have to sort out some of
the finer details of this plan including
how exactly to pay for it by the way the
treasury department says
that the first payments going out today
will total about 15
billion dollars reaching the families of
60 million
american children about 86
of the payments are going out by a
direct deposit so if you think you're
eligible
check your bank account gail a lot of
numbers there to digest thank you very
much ed o'keefe always good to see you